what is this why are you showing me this
this is opium I knew immediately that
I'd been used I knew immediately Ray had
set me up everything he had told me was
a lie
this guy that I known for a couple years
now and considered my friend very good I
just sent me up to unknowingly smuggle
drugs for him I felt like such an idiot
I need to speak with the American
Embassy
this little guy says to me embassy can't
help you
we're gonna hang you after the five
o'clock prayer
I'm terrified at this moment and I can't
believe this is happening to me someone
tells you they're gonna kill you can we
put the handcuffs on you now no one
there are even had a chance to hold me
down
all I heard is a gun being fired
I wasn't trying to escape I was trying
to find a phone I hit the ground and
just crashed through a door at the
hallway
start a barricade furniture for that
door just to turn that door into Cheez
Whiz and just shoot it all up
I figure bumping a guy I'm gonna make my
life worth something and I'm just gonna
warn others this is my last day on earth
I gotta make my life count zero nine
nine nine one one four one one anything
it was pointless outside in the hallway
out here I said I want to speak to
someone from the embassy American voice
from the embassy says DEA and then it
like cleared his throat he says uh yeah
they were kidding
Wow I was like how are you gonna kid
about something like that please come
with us mr. O'Day